she's now showing us a very special
v-day drink at that resort
so i planned on being at blacktop here
at the venetian but i didn't plan on my
partner
being named adrian so for you know in
the spirit of valentine's day we're
doubling as the iconic rocky couple
right that's right yeah
gotta start it off with some laughter
you know we're alignment we love
alignment for valentine's day and we
love
shakes and sweets for valentine's day so
let's get into this crazy shake cool
awesome so this is our red velvet cake
shake we do this every year for
valentine's day
we start off with a little bit of red
velvet cake base uh
vanilla frosting red and white sprinkles
to fit the mood
and of course a red velvet cake shake to
top it off otherwise it wouldn't be
crazy
it's true so what's the first step
because i know on instagram you guys
give full tutorials
for your shapes that's right first step
is always going to be getting frosting
around this rim here
so we're going to start with a little
vanilla around the rim go ahead and be
generous
excuse me being generous on valentine's
day we're still on brand good
once we get that in we'll get some of
our red and white sprinkles right here
beautiful a mess always happens so we
don't really mind that and this one's
special obviously for valentine's day
right that's right okay
so if you want to help me out a little
bit go ahead and throw some drizzle
around that cup right there
that's right just around this part it's
inside
wow okay perfect and then
right over here we got our shake base
yum so is that what a strawberry shake
what is that this is red velvet cake
powder duh you said that all right
so whipped cream always helps hold
things in place go ahead and throw that
cake right on top
i'm throwing i'm putting the cake on top
of the shake that's right slot down just
like that just like you got it
whoa go ahead and do another little bit
of whip okay
wow now you know why this is called
crazy
whipped cream excuse me go ahead and
throw the cherry on there and here i'll
help you out a little
heart out of chocolate boom see that
little you like that little
touch boom and that's about it right
there
crazy shake red velvet crazy take care
of blacktop i love it that's beautiful
how do you drink it that's my next
question
uh we get that question quite a bit here
it doesn't matter you figure it out
right
you figure it out as long as everyone's
having fun and speaking of dates now
blacktop
is a burger spot right that's right but
no one said burgers aren't romantic you
have a couple of romantic stories from
blacktop right
uh that's true actually uh very recently
we had a couple locals stop in
um the groom to be uh contacted us our
events manager carly
uh we got the staff involved the uh
unknowing
uh bride uh got a one of our vegan
shakes dropped off with a ring on it the
staff helped out we
got a recording of everything and that's
on instagram also too wow we love that
it's one of the best parts of love and
valentine's day are the stories right
absolutely so tell us really quick how
people can celebrate at the venetian
well in addition to coming to blacktop
there's plenty of great restaurants at
the venetian
the gondola rides are very popular and
not to mention there's a great view of
the strip outside also
all right adrian thank you so much i
will definitely try and figure this out
appreciate it i'll send it back to you
guys